hey what is up guys mkbhd here and this
is the sony sperry z and this little
slab of metal and glass here i found it
to be the most mixed bag of all time
allow me to explain when you're sony
you're going out to make the high-end
super phone to compete with the likes of
the galaxy note 2 and the droid dna and
other super high-end devices you'd go
all out right you would add you know
high-end materials high-end build
quality high-end internals high-end
software the whole works that's what you
expect when you get the sony xperia z so
taking a look at the body itself it's
definitely sexy you can't take that away
from it it's 7.9 millimeters thin and
it's got a piano black glass finish on
the front and the back so it's nice
there's a 13.1 megapixel rear facing
camera and led flash on the back and all
around the phone has a pretty solid
button layout the power button itself is
a great button it's really big and easy
to press and not too sensitive which is
nice doesn't go off in your pocket so
the whole right hand side is basically
the power button the volume rocker which
is less easy and the sim card tray and
on the left hand side you have your
micro sd card slot which is covered but
that allows for expandable storage so
you notice that all around this device
all the ports are covered and sealed by
plastic flaps this isn't actually a bad
thing this is a good thing because when
all these flaps are closed the xperia z
is water resistant for up to half an
hour and three feet of water so this
thing is actually a bit rugged they were
demoing it just like that at ces so if
you ask me this is a pretty tough device
every single important thing about this
device has something hugely awesome
about it and something hugely
disappointing about it everything about
this device so starting let's take take
a look at the camera it's half awesome
with a 13.1 megapixel sensor extremely
fast performance i noticed it takes
pictures and burst shots very very
quickly and it can take 1080p hdr video
so the capabilities are really high and
the very intelligent and fast autofocus
is really pleasing but it's it's pretty
versatile yet the images it produces
especially for landscapes tend to be
pretty soft with below average led flash
performance and overall not the best
image quality something comparable with
the galaxy nexus so on the software side
of things this guy is running android
4.1 jelly bean so that's not bad no word
on the 4.2 update but that is pretty
pretty recent and the positive side is
that this is one of the less obtrusive
skins on any android 4.1 device out
there so that's a good start that's a
good sign there's also not a whole lot
of sony bloatware not a whole lot of bad
pre-installed apps like we see on
verizon phones so that's pretty good and
the value adding features are definitely
welcome however i am not a fan of the
light gray software buttons at the
bottom and in the notification bar i
would have preferred these to be i guess
darker to match the black bezel or
lighter to be like more transparent but
that gray is just really awful in
between and that theme kind of permeates
throughout so you might not think it's
ugly but there is definitely room for
improvement with design here and then
there's performance this thing in terms
of performance flies i actually can't
take anything away from the performance
frame rates are constantly high the
thing just powers through the most
intensive apps and games without a
problem and that's thanks to the
qualcomm snapdragon s4 pro chip and two
gigabytes of ram so it's a quad core
thing and this just just flies and of
course kills benchmarks and you can
check out how it crushes through data
when browsing more image heavy sites
like the verge it's very well done but
basically overall performance is stellar
on par with the galaxy note 2 and it's
just about as good if you don't count
the huge battery in the note 2 but then
you have to look at that display now the
sony xperia z has a 1080p display yes it
does 440 ppi but that is kind of
becoming the megapixel count number and
it's extremely sharp and beautiful when
you view it head-on and if you're going
to be spending a lot of time on a
high-end smartphone like this you do
want it to have a sharp big beautiful
display because you're doing all the
looking on the display unfortunately the
good ends there it's kind of like having
a 37 megapixel camera that doesn't take
great photos when you look at this
display from even a few degrees off axis
the viewing angles the color
reproduction the contrast just goes
straight downhill you don't even have to
have it side by side with an oppo fine 5
or a droid dna to notice that this
display is subpar i mean it's definitely
not that good i haven't personally
looked at the htc ones display but from
the specs that i've seen i'm expecting
it to be really good so it's gonna be
hard to compete and this thing just it
lets me down i'm really disappointed the
viewing angles are the most
disappointing i couldn't have asked for
anything worse than this literally just
a few degrees off axis and it's
noticeably worse
and then there is the speaker
this is this is a terrible speaker in
fact i'll let you have a listen for
yourself
so this sperry z has its ups and its
downs like it has its really really high
ups and it's really really far downs i
know it's going to be hard to compare
this to the htc one and the droid dna
but it's going to be compared with those
1080p phones it's going to be compared
with the galaxy s4 and anything else
high-end that comes out this year but
the comparison is really crazy when you
try to put a semi-rugged water resistant
but also thin and elegantly designed
phone up against something that's just
going all out in one department you may
love the speria z and i wouldn't blame
you this thing is sexy but a lot of
people are going to pick it up just for
the design which itself is okay but
definitely think twice about what you
want in a phone and what you don't want
in a phone before throwing down the cash
so in the end what is the deal with the
sony xperia z
it is the biggest mixed bag
ever this one has so many things that
are good about it and so many things
that are bad about it now if it was all
bad or all good it would be easy to not
recommend this phone or to recommend
this phone but you really have to pay
attention to the goods and the bads and
pick what you like about it and what you
don't like about it and if they match up
with your values you might still go for
the spare uzi but for me they don't
align perfectly with the things that
i've gotten used to enjoying about a
phone that being said i still love the
pixel and see of a 1080p display and i'm
excited for the wars of the five-inch
1080p smartphones this year or even the
htc one which is a slightly smaller than
five inch screen and it's 1080p so i
like the fact that we're seeing more
1080p phones now but honestly it's just
getting to that point where you got to
make it good if you're going to have a
1080p display on a phone it has to be a
great display and for the price point
this is just such a hard recommend you
really have to look at your values also
another interesting fact and i guess a
bit of a disclaimer is this phone comes
out of the box with a screen protector
in the box but it also comes with a very
subtle screen protector already applied
on the phone it takes up the entire slab
of glass and the sony branding on the
front of the xperia z is actually
attached to the screen protector so if
you take it off it'll just be a
perfectly blank black slab which is kind
of cool but that screen protector is
probably the cause of some of the issues
i have with the display but honestly
it's a little bit weird that you can't
even really tell that the screen
protector is applied but i wouldn't take
it off of the display because taking it
off would mean pretty much exposing uh
that less than up to par display uh to
the elements and if you're going to have
a ruggedized phone you're probably going
to want to leave that on which of course
brings up the question is this a slick
beautiful designed well phone designer
phone or is this a really tough rugged
water resistant phone because it's
really hard to be both and i guess sony
tried to be both and that's where they
ended up having some contradictions in
this phone either way the choice is
yours do you like the sperry z i think
it's sexy but again it's all up to you
leave a comment down below the like
button on this video and uh the comment
section is open so you'll probably see
me replying to comments down there
either way thank you for watching and
i'll talk to you guys in the next video
peace
you